mark Stein is an author and columnist
and a close observer of all things
Russia plot-related and he joins us
tonight
so mark in my hand I have a document
that will end
MSNBC's prime time schedule which has
been predicated on the idea that Trump
is cluded with the Russians I almost
don't want to tell them because I don't
want to wreck their their ratings run
but what are they gonna do when they
find out what is CNN gonna do what is
the entire American media gonna do with
the fact that there was actually no
collusion I think they'll just carry on
as usual Tucker for that for the very
good reason that they happen to agree
with Putin on this Putin's object which
is a reasonable one for any hostile
power to take to other nations is that
he wanted to sow confusion and he wound
up sowing confusion because for the last
18 months the Democrats and the media
have run around like headless chickens
shrieking about some guy who happens to
be related to a cabinet secretary who
happens to find himself in a bar in the
Seychelles and a Russian walks into the
bar and it's actually not illegal to
talk to Russians in bars or Russians in
diners or Russians in department stores
that sort of crime so if you want to go
to a bar in the Seychelles and talk to a
Russian good luck to you and what
happened is that the great slow
elephantine process of American
investigations of this nature which is
always looking in the rearview mirror so
we raided investigating stuff that
happened two three years ago meanwhile
Putin's getting on with stealing the
next election because everybody else is
looking ahead while we're doing all this
rearview mirror stuff well that's a
great question
but the next question would be what
about the people whose lives have been
destroyed based on the understanding
they were in some way colluding with
Russia that would include Carter Paige
ambassador Flynn people who will never
work meaning a Philly again who had to
sell their houses who in Flynn's case
were indicted what happens to them just
does someone make them whole well I
think I think so and I actually think
that's a more serious
problem because I think there are
serious questions about corruption and
and excessive use of muscle at the
federal prosecutorial level I don't
think it's respectable that the federal
government wins 97% of the cases that it
drags into court
now that's thats adam hussain kim
jong-un levels of prosecutorial success
and americans should be ashamed of it
and americans who seem to think it's
clever that you can put the screws on
Mike Flynn and persuade him to plead
guilty to something just because he
doesn't want to have what's left of his
savings account cleaned out I think
that's disgusting
and rather than obsessing and worrying
about Russia for another two years I'd
like us to actually seriously address
what is wrong with federal prosecution
what is wrong with the FBI what is wrong
with the DOJ and clean it up because it
ain't respectable and Americans should
be ashamed of it but that's what we're
supposed to be doing the media aren't we
were supposed to be on the lookout for
bullies abusing their power and crushing
the weak with their power to their own
benefit that's going on and the
cheerleader's of it are the media know
and there's something very weird about
actually seeing the left who used to be
all about sticking it to the man doing
this thing as you just quoted the
so-called 17 intelligence agencies I
don't know why we need 17 intelligence
agencies but for some reason it seems to
impress left-wing journalists so if we
added another 32 intelligence agencies
and we had 49 there if we had 49 spook
agencies that say they'd be even more
impressed and these are the same people
by the way that the one practical thing
to come out of this thing is we need
election security in this country and
yet the same people who tell us that
they're scared about Russians
interfering in the election are the same
people all over the country who are
saying that illegal immigrants should
have the right to vote in which case if
a Venezuelan or a Colombian can vote why
the hell can't a Russian interfere in
their legs we can all get a piece of it
it's exactly right and they're the ones
defeating voter ID laws and are the ones
who are from online voting which can
easily be hacked and against
paper ballots it's totally disingenuous
those are not their concerns at all what
they worship is power that's what they
seek end of our session right there mark
thank you very much for putting on stack
up as always